got family here I do have family here
and your dad's here too you mean my dick
my dad's my family yeah oh I I honestly
didn't mean it like that
I thought you are gay you know your dad
who's not in the family I know the story
no my family uh we have my dad noting
your dad yeah dad yes yeah cuz I saw
your uncle I didn't know you're dead my
uncle is here and my dad is also here
and my brother is here you've met them
before right yes I have met them
yeah hello Vegas great to see you guys
again ha ha ha do not engage it's like
when we go to a comedy show there's like
a bachelorette bachelorette party table
and they're like just don't say yeah
yeah I like in those sorts of moments
where there are rowdy people in the
crowd like a bachelorette party like a
small fire like you're in the living
room yeah there's a fire on one of the
curtains yeah and you're just like so
I'm from Boston and you're ignoring yeah
the smoke and the crackling look the
rest of the crowd is also just like
uh-huh
good chowder and you're just hoping the
fire deals with you we might die but I
won't have to do any crowd work well
it's a dream country to have you back on
the program and it's crazy to see you on
Silicon Valley I watched the premiere
and you're so good oh thank you I I know
that sounds like late-night trickery but
literally I'm so proud of you so good oh
that was a weird time when you started
acting on Michael and Michael have
issues uh-huh
and I remember being like worried for my
friend like what if he can't act he's a
lot of stand-ups
oh wow that was the longest silence that
anyone's ever had on a TV show I know I
loved it it was beautiful but what
honestly what a relief you're incredibly
talented you guys oh thank you there's
no reason if you're a good stand-up that
you'll be a good actor no no but I mean
you know you get sort of channeling I
like it and you get really good too on
those sketches and stuff you like where
this is going you are pretty mean to
each other sometimes in a fun way
yeah that's just my accent um there was
this the worst thing I ever did was do
you remember at my roast yeah I did this
joke and i preffer should i preface it
with the jug I did about you yeah sure
go ahead and then I'll tell you the joke
I dated I still feel horrible about it I
said Kumail Nanjiani is here tonight
which means disease is somewhere out
there making him irrelevant it's the
beat home show classic no no no you
remember I tell you that because yours
is worse okay this is what so now I'm
down here and this is what my joke was I
can't believe I'm gonna stayed while
your dad's here I said I just gotten
divorced yeah and I said hey Pete your
ex-wife called I'm joking she would
never call you she's too busy with the
new baby in my defense she had just had
a new baby
and it was so new oh I'm so sorry oh oh
sorry oh wait yeah haha just a good slap
of caffeine and truth in the morning oh
I'm really sorry that his meditating
workout it's one of my it was such a
great night I had such a great day it
was awesome I got like emotional during
it because this is true is that if it
wasn't for you I'm gonna get emotional
again um I moved to New York hold my
hand
honestly Pete left me money would be
like that is that really okay honestly
when uh my wife and I moved to New York
we had no money and you lent us money
and never asked for it back and if it
wasn't for you I mean I would have had
to go back to Chicago and I would be
like trying to get an agent so I could
get on this show haha oh yeah it wasn't
for you yeah whatever good that's very
nice we just say never ask